[Music]
now yo the framing of this conversation
today we're going to start off by
talking about yourself then we're going
to talk a little bit about South Africa
for reasons that will become very
self-evident and then we're going to
talk about Emerging Markets generally
before asking the qu the audience a few
questions and letting them ask us
questions too how does that sound to you
great let's do it are you feeling okay I
know that we're both really quite jetl
today you know it's a parallel time zone
yes yeah true good I think we can get a
lot more jokes of that of that ilk today
so the first thing um I wanted to say
was you know what are you doing why is
there BOS on your hats and I guess final
question to that what do you stand
for um well the first uh question is
easier to answer so um I've been you
know like a bunch of the people here
I've been uh
uh in Bitcoin for a very long time
Vintage
2011 you know the Vintage that is
already starting to turn into vinegar um
and What attracted me like a lot of
people to bitcoin was this idea that we
can build systems which are parallel and
separate and can protect us and also
free us from the existing institutions
that we saw as extremely limiting and
highly corrupt and and Bitcoin was this
rallying cry you know a lot of people
had been really interested in these
ideas agorism uh anarchism anarco
capitalism all kinds of new you know New
Hampshire free state all kinds of ideas
but suddenly Bitcoin arrived and it
became like this flag on a hill and
attracted people from all walks of life
to thinking okay here we actually have
something where we can get some traction
some Leverage so for me BTC was always
like the special case a a a specific
example of what we can do with self
enforcing
self-regulating
systems um and systems that can um
because they're encoded Ed in code can
be both transparent and Incorruptible
and what I've always wanted to do is
expand upon that um to all assets and
then beyond that to all kinds of
Institutions so Bitcoin OS uh is a is a
project that seeks to do that and we've
had some very fundamentally exciting
almost like Miracle type um
technological breakthroughs recently a
few months ago for the first time ever
we were able to demonstrate the ability
to verify ZK proofs on bitcoin this
means that we can now take any form of
compute and convert it into a proof that
is executable on Bitcoin so we can
basically we we basically uh have turned
Bitcoin into a fully functional scalable
smart contract platform it means we can
introduce native privacy into Bitcoin it
means that we can have rollups to
bitcoin it means that you can build
applications and institutions that are
governed by Bitcoin proof of work as the
high court and so now we've started to
see a bunch of uh projects begin to
build in this the largest and sort of
the one which got the most excitement
was um cardan
and a big part of the cardano community
announced that they were going to become
a Bitcoin layer too um but uh uh we've
seen just across the board a lot of
excitement not directly sort of
necessarily related to what we're
discussing now but but thematically the
same thing no and it helps to answer
that question as well what do you stand
for I think you definitely encapsulated
in there um yeah I mean just to rebound
of what you were saying there I think
Bitcoin has certainly rekindled that
cypherpunk movement
however it definitely has lost its way
but we are seeing to steal your uh words
there it is finding some Traction in
Emerging Markets notably your home
country I don't know if you can tell but
yes Yago is from South Africa still a
slight uh South African accent there in
your hometown of South Africa there's
actually a lot of really interesting
Bitcoin projects taking place which are
these sort of parallel Societies or
Bitcoin circular economies as sometimes
called one is Bitcoin akazi another one
is Bitcoin viten there's also Bitcoin
I've just forgotten it name but will
come back to me in a moment um but I
wanted to ask first talk to us about
South Africa it is an Emerging Market of
course but to what extent is the nation
H how to frame this to what extent is
the nation serving people you know how
how far is the South African system
working right now in 2024 well I think
it's um it's no secret that South
Africa is on its way to failed State
status right it's lost the ab ility to
provide electricity to huge amounts most
of the population its crime rates are
among the highest in the world violent
crime and sexual crime in particular um
uh there's a a a a a a reduction for
significant parts of the population in
life
expectancy um and
um the the the sort
of um Genie coefficient the inequality
that was apparent during aparte South
Africa has not improved at all so the
genie coefficient hasn't moved um so
really what South Africa did was replace
one set of corrupt Elite with a another
set of corrupt Elite it's true I mean I
I spent a month in South Africa this
January and I was shocked actually how
much is on the individual to create
their own sort of parallel societies at
home you know you have to have your own
electricity generator you have have to
have your own source of water you have
to grow your own vegetables a lot of
people just keep chickens and that's
within the sort of middle and upper
class societies and then within the sort
of less fortunate you know there's a lot
of townships going on these are some
some of these are black townships some
of these are the cape colored townships
and it's just a really fractured and
fractur Society because of that and I
wanted to drill into this a bit more
because I think what's going on in South
Africa is being echoed in lots of
emerging markets and to some extent the
ukuk which you can also SP speak of um
around the world um so why is this
happening and can we really um help to
remedy or solve some of these problems
so I think it was really interesting the
question that you asked the audience
earlier you asked what are some examples
of parallel societies today and you just
brought up a really good example of
parel society if you go to South Africa
if you're living in South Africa today
you are most likely not relying on the
police for security you have a private
security Force you are most likely not
relying on the National Health Care
System uh and you may even be part of a
group which has its own ambulance
service um you likely have your own
generator um and you know are managing
your own power and so that is the
reality of a parallel society and it's
very very widespread in South Africa
some groups have gone further there's a
town called Orna in the orange free
state or what used to be called the
Orange Free State we just get to show up
hands has anyone heard of Ora or maybe
visited yeah there's quite a few YouTube
documentaries about it it's well worth
checking out but um so AR is one of the
best examples of a thriving and
successful uh community in South
Africa um but if I tell you about it
you're almost certainly going to hate
it why is that because Arna only has
white Afric is living there they don't
allow anyone else in they have their own
school system they have their own
everything they've built an entire
parallel Society for themselves
basically a
citadel um and um you know they the the
the Africana Calvinism that religious
aspect of life is very important they
don't allow black workers in um because
they believe that that was the the the
the original sin uh relying on the work
of other people uh was a problem um it
it it corrupted their society and so
they've created a white Enclave now it's
very nice if you go there um but I
suspect that for most people uh there's
something very disturbing maybe even
stomach turning about it now the reason
I think it was an interesting question
people you know you asked are there
examples of um of of good parel
societies and somebody said get up
I think we should get
serious right we need to be serious
about the actual state of parallel
societies and what it is that we're
trying to accomplish and what the price
that we might want to pay and where it
might end up here's a few really
successful parallel societies arania
which we've already discussed the Amish
right they're paying a very significant
price they're living 400 years in the
past a very very successful Society or
was Su very very successful until about
a month ago uh was
hisbah healah had set up their own
military they had set up their own
Judicial System they had their own
Financial system their own school and
health system all based around their uh
Shia ideology and they basically took
over the entire country of
Lebanon um and um in terms of living by
their own uh uh worldview they were
doing a very very good job I mean they
they kind of screwed it up over the last
month but that was one of the most
significant parallel societies the Kurds
in Northern Iraq that's a parallel
Society the um the the country of Israel
right you'll notice that that area of
the world has a lot of parallel
societies right country of Israel today
in many ways one of the most hated uh uh
countries in the world is probably the
best example we have of an intentional
Society here were a group of people
persecuted for thousands of years who
decided to get together and create a
society which would uphold their values
and allow them to protect themselves
their children future generations and to
to to to create a culture and a language
of their own um that was a parel society
uh parallel society which is sort of
diminishing now the United States of
America United States of America was
explicitly set up as a parallel Society
what is left of that today well I mean
you got Cala versus Trump right uh
there's been a dilution of the the the
ideological underpinnings of the United
States so it is now just a society not a
parallel Society but we've lost
something right these are all of course
um a lot of those are more areas of sort
of conflicts whereas some of these are
natural paralel
what's what's the most common parallel
Society in the world the one which has
all of the things that we were talking
about in the last panel the ability to
maintain reputation the ability to have
enforcement mechanisms the ability to
manage Commerce and trade that is global
and significant the biggest one biggest
one uh I was going to go somewhere like
Orthodox Jews or something like that
organized crime organized crime okay
that was whale parallel Society par
Excellence right what is a parallel
Society there some a group of people who
have decided to opt out of the rules
that is like literally the definition of
organized crime so the question I have
is do we have the stomach to be
organized criminals or are we just
laring because if we want to actually
create parallel societies there's a
number of costs there's a number of
prices we have to first of all reject
the existing Society we defend facto
become criminals second we are engaging
in an inherently
elitist activity right who says to
himself you know those rules not for me
I'm not going to live by those rules I
I'm going to make my own rules that is
an inherently elitist idea right and
then there is also the question of
exclusivity because if you look at the
United States of America the United
States of America over time has diluted
from its initial constitutional
underpinnings
because you know when something gets
popular it stops being cool so you kind
of need to keep things exclusive so so
there there's very significant real
questions about whether or not we
actually have the stomach to do what
we're talking about it's funny you
mentioned that and we're actually seeing
those Trends in ratan where they created
this you know parallel Society the
island just off on jurus a lot of local
were quite vocal in their opposition to
this because in a way they are as you
say de facto breaking the law if we just
go back to South Africa the I know
irania and by the way one thing on
arania I couldn't join arania because
I'm not Africans by Blood it's not just
white people it's Africans not about
blood it's about being able to speak
Africans and accepting Africana version
of Calvinism oh okay I thought it
literally had to be afrian BL okay um so
yeah back to South Africa there are
these Bitcoin circular economies being
built there one is in a Township um just
outside muscle Bay another one is in
this place called witon and there
because the Rand of the sou African
currency is effectively one of the
world's greatest shitcoins they are
trying to phase out its use by paying
workers by onboarding shops and by using
Bitcoin as their not just their store of
value but also their medium of exchange
I didn't actually reflect on the fact
that's technically going against the
legal tender version which is you must
use the South African rand so my
question to you yo is how much easier is
it to to create these parallel Societies
in countries where the na nation state
has for once of a better word failed or
is definitely you know failing is that
where we should focus our efforts
effectively ah is that where we should
focus our efforts well I don't know
about me and you but you know
collectively okay so so I'm going to I'm
going to rephrase that question right so
unquestionably it's easier to create
parallel societies where the existing
sort of society the default Society is
weak
MH um
um but do we want to do that because the
the price that you pay for that there
are all kinds of potential prices but
the the primary price that you pay for
that is you have to potentially
significantly downgrade your standard of
living yeah right or you're going to
live as sort of an elite within a much
more impoverished
environment and um if you know we take
the example of prosperis I I was uh
involved actually the very first talk I
ever gave at a Bitcoin conference was
about creating free zones in Honduras I
I I've been involved just you know
almost from the beginning patri fredman
got involved before I did but we were
the team competing with
patri um you know there's something
interesting let me if I may ask a
question of the audience how many people
here have served in the military or a
military okay so we got 1 2 3 4 five of
keep your hands up
please keep your hand up Sir how many of
you were conscripted if you were
conscripted lower your
hand so you were a volunteer so we' out
of this entire audience of people who
want to set up parallel Society we've
had one person volunteer to pick up a
gun and protect a society so the reason
I the reason I I rais this is because we
actually you know could have a parallel
Society
tomorrow uh prospera on the uh on the
island of
ratan is uh has has has taken us Mo 90%
of the way there it's currently being
threatened with closure by the
government of Honduras now the island of
ratan is as far away from the mainland
of Honduras as Taiwan is from
China the Chinese are a pretty big
prosperous and advanced country and
they're trying to figure out can we can
we actually invade Taiwan there's not a
chance in hell that Honduras can
properly invade ratan if ratan was
willing to put up even the smallest
amount of resistance so basically if the
bunch of us here were willing to get on
a plane now now you know go down to the
airport now fly over to Honduras pick up
you know a gun and declare independence
we would have an independent parallel
Society it wouldn't even be parallel it
would just be a society we'd have an
independent Society you know 12 hours 13
hours is the time of the flight from
now it's not going to happen we're not
advocating for that either by the way
put the put the why are we not
advocating because we're not advocating
for violence generally there's nothing
violent about that the gun bit is a bit
viol no guns are not violent there's
nothing VI did you shoot anyone when you
were in the military that you guys have
you shot
anyone I've been shot at but I've never
shot anyone so it's got nothing to do
with violence it's got to do with the
willingness to apply violence if
necessary okay okay right there's a very
very very big
difference and it's actually the other
price of it it's the willingness to
potentially be in a situation where
somebody May maybe it will apply
violence towards
you right now we're here we're pretty
self-satisfied a bunch of us have BTC or
eth or Soul or whatever right we can
travel the world we can mostly create
sort of these atomistic parallel
societies for ourselves somehow wle our
way you know go down to Puerto Rico
manage to escape taxes fly around to
wherever the weather is nicest half of
the people in the are doing this mhm but
we don't have a parallel Society we we
we we we we've got people who are
hiding right and I think part of the
question is do you know Society itself
is a price that you have to pay it's
basically now I'm going to have to get
together with a bunch of people and
agree to live with them with rules that
will constrain all of us how do you get
people to even opt into that so yeah I
know I've taken us a great it but I've
been to a few of these conferences
before I I really care about this stuff
and sometimes I feel like the
conversations are a little bit milk
toast right oh we're going to do this D
thing
and I I would like us to be asking
ourselves a serious questions which is
do we actually even want
this
right there's a there's a trade-off here
and most of us have pretty pretty nice
lives and so the the two extremes I
think are you this this conversation on
this panel sort of was titled Emerging
Markets are parallel societies that we
would recognize as parallel societies
going to emerge from Emerging Markets no
no they're not going to be places we're
going to want to live in they're going
to be fundamentalist in ways that we
wouldn't like they're going to be
violent and poor in ways that we
wouldn't like the Emerging Market is not
going to develop The Cutting Edge of
tomorrow's societies if they were there
wouldn't be emerging markets and on the
other hand and this is the more
uncomfortable thought are the kind of
par societies that we're imagining going
to emerge from
us there I maybe have to answer the
answer no as well because maybe we we
have it too good we don't actually need
it we like to fantasize it certainly
certainly paus for thought there but I
mean I've got to play Devil's Advocate
and and try to hoping that we you know
we're coming down questions I'm hoping
I'm going to get reamed here no I mean
you mentioned that Emerging Markets are
unlikely places for these parallel
societies to emerge and yet we have
Bitcoin Beach and El Salvador which of
course led to El Salvador then adopting
Bitcoin as legal tender for the two
years prior to na buele you know making
this decree that was a parallel Society
where people were using Bitcoin instead
of the US dollar um you know I've
already mentioned Bitcoin akazi there's
Bitcoin viton there's of course the
Bitcoin jungle there's even a small
project just north of here in um sorry
the jet lies talking what's the name of
that sort of nomad hot spot in the north
changai changm there's a sort of Bitcoin
project going there in lots of African
nations whether it's Ghana whether it's
the Ivory Coast there are these small
Bitcoin circular economies starting so
we are seeing the Grassroots initiatives
spread out somewhat so I think that yeah
while we've got it good yeah we're all
sitting here at this lovely conference
Hall we are seeing clearly you know
evidence of these parallel societies
being built from the ground up and the
first thing they're addressing is money
they might not be addressing stuff like
blockchain governance and sort of the
decentralized ideas that we've all sort
of listen to today but they're at least
trying to address that first issue which
is we have broken money we now have a
tool to fix that so that that was my
first point about the you know is it
going to come from the urging markets
the call to action of everyone here yeah
I think that's an absolutely fair thing
to say I think that while we all act on
our ideas as best as we can with our own
personal intentions like for example I I
left the UK the day after the brexit
vote because I was like I can't deal
with this country anymore um you left
South Africa because well I'm I'm
assuming here but you know I guess there
wasn't the opportunity there that you
wanted when you you grew up there
whatever it may be like we are still
doing something we are still voting with
our feet are we going to come together
and create a parallel Society well I
don't know if it's going to be a
physical space that's the thing right
these I mean today we've effectively
created a parallel Society in this
building where we have lots of
like-minded individuals getting to the
nitty-gritty of these things so okay
when is that going to convert into a I
don't know we haven't mentioned Liber
land right you know Liber land the idea
that's going to be libertarian Utopia
anyone visited liba land Liber land in
you have good man great it's still on my
list of places to go to but it's very
hard to take a boat across so we are
seeing the sort of the inklings of these
things within the developed or like more
privileged people around the world um
would you pick up a gun and get to one
of these uh these parallel societies
would you defend it I already have um
you defended London with a gun not in
London no so I was part of the Israeli
military for a while okay and I among
other things was in charge of protecting
a a group of people who I really really
disliked um settlers in the West Bank so
I I was sent to act as a as a guard for
settlers and I loathed these people I
loathed them before I met them but I lo
them way more after I met them but they
had a parallel Society
and um and and um I ended up becoming a
conscientious objector in the Israeli
military and there's a question that I
ask myself maybe once every month is did
I become a conscientious objector
because I'm a
selfish person who was not willing to
make sacrifices and and and I felt like
it was easier to become a conscientious
objector than to get shot at again or
did I become a conscientious objector
because of the reasons that I thought I
was doing it at the time which was my
moral underpinning and my moral my my my
my my my my disagreement with you know
the
geopolitical and and and ethnostate
aspects of of of of Israeli settler
philosophy and I think it's a bit of
both MH
so um you just a little bit about me I
I've sort of experienced a lot of these
things very very seriously my my family
were members of
thec uh during the aparte government
they some of them were forced to flee
South Africa when I was a young boy I
was smuggling money to my family members
who had been uh designated as T
terrorists by the aparti
government
um H yet uh so so so sort of that was
that was that was my first experience
with that I I I I grew up
uh in my later years in Israel I served
in the military I um volunteered in um
Arab uh neighborhoods and Arab schools I
lived in an Arab neighborhood from for
most of the years that I was there and I
experienced in a very very real way how
their society is very very different
from ours in ways that we find
uncomfortable to
admit um and then I got involved in in
prospera sort of before it was even
called prospera uh out of a strong sense
that we can change the constitution of
huras but in in changing the
Constitution of huras at the time we
were partly uh doing so in partnership
with a government that had fired at
Supreme Court and then repacked the
Supreme Court with people that knew
would would would not overturn the laws
that they were trying to introduce it's
the reality of all of these situations
has been extremely
messy so um Bitcoin is is is is awesome
because Bitcoin is is pure it's clean
right it's it's it's it's detached from
our physical world it doesn't have the
the violent aspects or so I thought but
a few days ago after Trump won I was
having a conversation with one of
my increasingly fewer and fewer nocoiner
friends and he was very very upset that
Trump won and I explained to him that I
thought that even if we really dislike
Trump that uh and even if Trump turns
out to be an authoritarian that the
long-term view is that this changes the
trajectory of the world and edges it
bends it more towards freedom and the
reason I said is because basically we've
had a crypto industry which has been
sanctioned by the United States
government for its entire history and
yet has still become the fastest
growing um Market in the world and the
freest Market that has ever existed but
now the United States government was
going to stop sanctioning this Singapore
in the sky and then he said sure but the
the the the the ice is going to start
bursting into you know could burst into
your your house and and and take away
your immigrant wife uh to to some kind
of camp and I said well that's extremely
unlikely if if we think that we're being
being targeted by Ice we can just leave
and then
he said something which was very
illustrative he said it sounds to me
like you're saying you're going to be
fine and everyone
else that's a risk and I disagree with
that but I think it's very very
illustrative because what I think he's
saying is two things at once one is yes
you are more free than me now because
you bought a whole bunch of Bitcoin 10
years ago and now you can go anywhere
you want I'm stuck in wherever is that
I'm living with my kid and my shitty job
and my you know Etc bank account The
crucial I don't have that freedom I
don't live in your parallel world and
second you are happy for Trump to maybe
bend the trajectory of the world in the
long term but in the short term I think
that this is going to introduce a lot of
authoritarianism for a very for a large
SWA of relatively vulnerable
people and so you know the the the
unevenness of it so here I actually have
a call to to action here one of I've
been thinking about this dilemma for a
long time and and and and I think the
Crux of it for me has come down to this
idea that we have a central dilemma in
our philosophy in our moral our our our
our our under moral underpinnings of our
philosophy on on the one hand we are
elitist we want meritocracy we want
growth we want free markets on the other
hand we're universalists we want
transparency we want code is law we want
everyone is on the same footing right
fair drop air drop right like and I
think those two things are
inherently at
odds I think that
universalism in many ways is a is a
category error
because the moral value of something the
ethical value of something is very very
context
dependent if uh you know there are a
woman out there not a few of them
hundreds of millions of them who really
do believe that they feel more
comfortable covering up and they'll give
you a lot they'll they'll spend an hour
explaining to you why women who are not
covering up are you know being exploited
and they will make sense it's a rational
argument and um and so for them right in
their context that is a better life that
is the moral thing to
do and so you know we've got this sort
of like I think pseudo Christian
universalism that all people need to
have the same moral precepts the same
ethical ideas
and I think that we cannot create
parallel societies so long as we hold on
to that so the controversial call to
action that I'm going to suggest here is
that we need as a
minimum we need to embrace
elitism right we need to say yes I'm
elitist and I'm proud not elitist
because I'm better than other people I'm
elitist because I think I'm better than
other people right maybe they're maybe
they think they're better than than me
and they they get to have that right but
I know I'm better than them and I'm
willing to separate myself from society
and I'm willing to create for myself a
society which will not be porous it will
be exclusive it will not be Universalist
it will be voluntary right but that also
means we voluntarily get to exclude
those who might dilute our society until
we're willing to
make that minimum sort of
seriousness or or that minimum um level
of sacrifice and this is you know I'm
not talking about picking up guns or
going to ran or you know doing
experiments you know on you know you
know or or paying poor people for their
kidneys I'm not I'm no nowhere near that
right I'm just saying are you willing to
get into a room and say the people in
this room get to be here and no one else
I think that is like the bare minimum of
what is required for us to actually
build a parallel Society okay thank you
yo food for thought for everyone we do
have five minutes for questions here if
you'd like to ask a question please do
hop up there's one man already on the
way to the microphone and yeah dwell on
that are you willing to Chuck people out
a room I'm joking by the way um yes hey
that was super interesting also very
colorful so thank you for that and
getting bit back to the original
question here though how Bitcoin changed
the Emerging Markets I I I'm from
Germany so when I come here I'm amazed
how good 5G is and um I think when you
when you come from Europe or you come
from the US and you have all these black
black spots on the map that have no
coverage you realize that in a lot of
countries that have built uh this
infrastructure more recently they leap
frocked like putting cables in the sand
and and all of that and they leap
frocked it to something better where
they have really really good coverage
usually right and so for a lot of
Emerging Markets they're also doing it
because the leap frogging is so so much
cheaper and I'm thinking like isn't that
also true with money Printing and
monetary policy and this is isn't this
where Bitcoin is coming in right you if
you have like you have a problematic
country maybe it is falling it's a
failing State and now you have the thing
coming afterwards and it and they need
to start fresh and they need to set up
factories and how do we bring like money
to people and do we have to have Bank
buildings everywhere isn't like leap
frogging to bitcoin like the natural
thing they would do and do you see that
somewhere happening like or where would
you think that Happ so so this is also
brought up uh in the question in El
Salvador which I didn't address and I
think the answer is yes and I think it
supports my thesis so um there's two
ways that bitcoiners and everyone else
but bitcoiners have been talking about
El Salvador one is oh this is this is
the way it's happening right the other
is we are coing up to a dictator and
really Bitcoin was designed to defeat
defeat the states not support the
state and there's some truth in both of
those but the reality is that El
Salvador is leapfrogging it has
massively improved its uh its its
reserves right they started buying
Bitcoin four years ago they've made a
lot of money on the Bitcoin that they've
purchased um they've introduced a um
parallel payments mechanism which
doesn't require Banks their economy is
BL is booming and has been um nothing to
do with Bitcoin it has to do with
something else which I'll come to in a
second and um the the you know the come
to it now and all of this has to do with
a strong man right here is a man who
usurped democracy took a country that
was
democratically failing on a continuous
basis said let's be let's get real was
willing to be exclusionary he took a
huge chunk of the population and put
them you know you don't get much more
exclusionary than putting them in in in
in camps right um and he changed the
trajectory of the country and now it's
gone from the most violent country in
the Americas to the safest so I think
that's illustrative
yes you can leap frog Bitcoin
represented one way of leap progging it
and it was part of and I think
frequently needs to be part of a package
deal yeah no I really like this question
and I think we do see a lot of this leap
grogging stuff I mean in Europe you know
we had Poland which never had checks
like checkbooks in Poland which were
just never a thing because by the time
their banking infrastructure took sort
of took off people had already advanced
actual checking accounts as opposed to
writing checks and I mean you can look
at yeah Salvador's classic example going
to Bitcoin in Kenya bank accounts aren't
really a thing mobile payments are so
they leap frogged with empa so can we
get more and more micronations parallel
states to adopt Bitcoin and just
LeapFrog the the horror that is Central
Banking I think we can but there's also
a lot of ways to fail in this I mean you
know the strongman authoritarian
trajectory is a little bit alarming
particularly to the Western eye of you
know we we we're brought up to to fear
and rever these kind of people um in El
Salvador it's clearly working at the
expense of I don't know how many
thousands of people who were locked up
unlawfully or at least unlawfully in our
eyes in their eyes it's their law and
that's you know that's their thing um
there's one more thing I wanted to say
on there and it was about um yeah these
I think these circular economies are one
of the ways or one of the best ways
rather to unlock that sort of Leap Frog
effect and to go from there a lot of
Emerging Markets they go from hyperin
lating currency to dollarization to
eventually the to bitcoin maybe
Argentina might be one to you know take
this next leap frogging step so I'm I'm
hopeful but I think also it's just a
matter of education and matter of time
but thank you very much for your
question I think we've got time for one
more are you okay for one more yeah
thank you again hey good afternoon hey
my name is uh guaman I'm from claros and
I live in Singapore claros I work at
claros but I live in Singapore right now
uh just have a question regarding few of
the themes that you touched on just now
you talked about the intentionality of
people uh engaging in parallel societies
sorry it to the mic oh okay yeah so just
now you talked about um the
intentionality of people that are um
engaging in parallel societies you talk
about elitism and you talk about that
many of us in this room is actually like
actually hiding from the jurisdiction
that we actually belong to right so what
do you think is actually like the the
perfect profile of someone that a
parallel Society want to have is is
someone who's like Pious loyal and arant
sticking to you know the society that
they choose to be or just some a person
that is more like a sovereign individual
more mercenary picking the best parts of
his society that they are part of and um
running when they face obligations that
they don't want to be part of every year
Chang Ma has a season where everyone
needs to leave because uh it f the
valley fills with smoke because people
are burning the the the
forest and so the Nomad community of
changai which is very very cool is
extremely nomadic but they get together
once every six
months now they tend to be younger or if
not younger they tend to be
childless and I think for those people
they're highly mobile and they can live
their lives they don't really need a
parallel Society Society kind of sucks
society sucks why would you want to live
in society Society is a bunch of other
people you need to smell them you need
to hear them you need to go live by
their rules you need to compromise with
them society
sucks when do you need
Society sometimes you need Society
because of Health right because you need
some kind of critical mass you know do I
want to go to the hospital in changai
maybe I want to create a place where
that becomes more important when you're
older I suspect that for most of us
where it where the rubber hits the the
dirt is is when we start thinking how
are we going to be raising our children
right and because that is that that is a
a sort of a thing which goes beyond your
ephemeral day to-day sort of indulgences
and now you're creating a life I have
this problem right I want to be able to
raise my children with a set of values
with a set of Excellence with a with a
sense of meritocracy and with the set of
of
morals that that appeal to me right
maybe we can do this you know we create
an AI in the sky and everyone goes and
gets hom skilled someone's in changmai
and someone's in prospera and someone's
in you know San Francisco and I think
that it's nice for kids to meet up so my
I suspect that as some of us like some
people are on the trajectory to be
completely childless and they're going
to have fun and good for them but I
think for those of us who have children
are going to have children that is the
the primary driver of the willing to
make the sacrifices that are necessary
to actually build a society awesome okay
I sorry just one last followup question
so how would you distinguish between
like your friend group your your family
the people that you basically surround
your children with and a parallel
Society where do you draw the line
quickly quickly
um I I think I would draw the line at
um intentionality right I'm kind of
stuck with
my not stuck with my friends but like my
my friends are like I I the the people I
drank with when I was in my 20s right my
family
are you know the people who were
drinking together and now I'm here
right uh the intentionality is you know
let's get together and create a school
that's that's intentional cool thank you
thank you so much for your question
please give it up hio
[Music]